- The old world was you got, you started
a brand and you fucking paid
to get even a prayer of getting in.
Now you build a $100
million dollar business,
direct to consumer, and
you're going in with leverage.
This is one big game of leverage.
(upbeat music)
(cheering)
You got your perspective.
I just want to be happy,
don't you want to be happy?
(upbeat music)
Super excited that you're here.
Excited for this fireside chat.
We have plenty of seats
so everybody standing
in the back feel free to fill out.
I apologize if I rush out on a whim.
I gotta get to the airport
and I've learned my
lesson on missing flights
in this town in the past, so I'll be
following D-Rock's call
and so let's get into it.
- Yeah nice, so my name's
Rebecca, I'm a senior reporter
at The Drum and I cover brand, digitals,
and I'm excited to be here today
to chat about pure digital brands,
and I guess we can kick
off by talking about
Empathy Wines, which
honestly I want to try.
Can you give me a bit of
insight into into why you wanted
to chat, seeing big
trends and brands moving
into the DtC space.
We were watching your clip.
You got that?
- For context you know, I
wrote one of the first checks
into Birchbox and a lot
of early kind of 2011,
12 DTC movement and obviously
in the last 24 months,
because of the sheer scale
of the underpriced attention
of Facebook and Instagram and
the amount of capital that
is available and the growth
of Shopify and Amazon.
All these macrotrends have
led to an enormous growth
of direct consumer brands.
So I'm watching that and
obviously my great thesis
of creating VaynerMedia was
to buy nostalgic brands,
so I haven't been highly
motivated to do Gym Shark,
or Fashion Nova, or you know, Hims.
Like that, that's not
where my passion lies,
though I've been seeing all the growth.
In parallel, I had two specific
executives at Vaynermedia
that were part of a team
called the Office of the CEO
so in theory, a couple
years ago, I realized how
stretched I was so I
created a team to act like
a chief of staff and
there was four of them
and after a year of it, it
just wasn't as efficient.
You know, I moved to
on chief of staff which
has been working much
better, but I had these
you know, multiple executives
that were super talented.
Two of them, John Trowman and Nate Troder,
who are my partners in
Empathy Wine, have been with
me since they were interns
in my wine business before
VaynerMedia and then came to Vayner.
John had left and worked
for a distributor even,
for a year and 1/2 and came back.
So, as an entrepreneur, we're
making this macrodecision
on the Vayner side, I'm sitting
with these incredible human
assets which is really,
kind of the KPI of the whole
Vayner thing to begin with.
There's this incredible push
of DTC and, as a third layer,
I'm weirdly missing wine
for the first time, right?
When you do something for
20 years, and its like
the only thing you're passionate about,
you get burnt out, and so
when I left Wine Library
to do Vayner, it was so refreshing
and I was excited to not
even think about wine,
and then a couple years later it was fun
because I started looking
at wine like a consumer,
you know my whole life, I'd go out
to a restaurant like
they're making a fork-ton
of money off this and this wine sucks
and all that kind of stuff and so,
that got fun and it
started becoming fun again.
Nobody was doing anything super crazy.
There were some wine clubs that were
doing incredibly well
but there's no purebred,
direct to consumer brand
at the kind of scale,
so that's why it happened.
We're off to an incredible start.
We've sold almost $2,000,000
worth of inventory
in the first six months without spending
any media dollars, all off
organic, against my brand.
We did that as a strategy to see if
we could gleam insights at scale
for my audience to make
us deploy the media even
in a better way, the AB testing against
Gary fans versus wine drinkers as a whole.
And so, the next year
for Empathy is gonna be
really exciting because
I think we're really
now gonna act like a brand more so than
the leverage off a personal brand.
- Well yeah, you mentioned that actually.
I'm interested to find out
more about the media plan
and what that looks like for Empathy Wine
'cause you launched it on Instagram.
Is that the most important
platform in your business?
- You know, the funny part is I'm not sure
and we launched it everywhere, right?
You might have saw it on Instagram,
but we put out YouTube
and podcast and Twitter
and Linkedin and email and
you know, we're pretty excited
to go as many platforms as possible.
To bring this much value here,
I think one thing for
everybody to think about
with direct to consumer
brands is to understand,
I set up earlier, the phenomenon
on the consumer's side
of why it's happening.
There's a very important thing that
I said very quickly and I'll say it again.
There's so much capital
in the world today,
that VCs have to deploy it.
That's how they live and one thing that
everybody really needs
to realize about some
of these incredible
brands that we all love,
on Instagram, or pre-roll
YouTube, or wherever you see them
is most of them are actually underwater.
They're raising so much
capital is so they can
play a game where their
customer acquisition is $31
but their margin on that is 19
so they're 12 bucks underwater.
Our clients at VaynerMedia, for example,
or established businesses that are
held accountable to Wall
Street can't do that
and so, there is some
incredible things that
are going on with these
brands but if tomorrow,
the global economy starts
to start the process
in the other direction,
98% of that brands that
we think are crushing it
will be out of business
'cause they won't be able
to raise the next round,
they're too underwater,
the math doesn't work
on customer acquisition and profitability
and it's game fucking over.
And so we need to have a little bit better
of a conversation, we need to have more
of a practical conversation around
DTC brands to realize
many of the ones that
we put on a pedestal,
I would say my friends,
it doesn't take a hero to
lose money every month.
And I think we need to be thoughtful that
a lot of these brands are
not building actual brand,
they're really CAC and LTB
conversion sales machines that
are arbitraging against
influencers or Instagram
and they need to be very thoughtful about
building brand right now because when
shit hits the fan, it will be brand that
will get them through the dark time.
- What is a nice way for DTC
brands to build brand then?
We're seeing a lot like our
old, instructional TV ads
from these companies.
(sighing)
- I think it's a huge mistake and I think
you're seeing it because
they're wasting money
and they don't care and I
think that the biggest delta
is we literally, what's amazing
to watch these brands go
so heavy on traditional,
above the line creative,
is that the great case study
of modern creative comes
in the form of Dollar Shave Club.
The Dollar Shave Club
video is this generation's
Just Do It or Where's the Beef.
It really is an iconic
piece of creative that
birthed the billion dollar brand.
The number one mistake that
direct to consumer brands
at scale are making
right now is not creating
long form video on Facebook and YouTube
to build brand equity.
And that's how I see it
and I think there are
a couple brands that are
actually, for that matter,
Purple Mattress.
If you nerd on this stuff,
you should go look at what
Purple Mattress is doing
as a company versus what Casper is doing
as a company, right?
One is very hardcore DTC
and is growing as a leader,
Casper, the Purple is
creating a lot of creative.
The $180,000 production
and creative execution risk
of making a funny video, a
video that makes you cry,
a video that makes you
think, if you hit that,
your CAC and LTB numbers
get really good real fast,
'cause now you're trading on brand
and that's the ultimate goal.
- And then in terms of platforms--
- Yes
- Does that mean for
social media platforms,
retailers, what does the shift mean?
- Well, it means that the
Facebooks of the world,
the Googles of the world
are getting more of their,
I mean it's crazy, ou have
two gals in the middle
of nowhere, starting a direct to consumer
peanut butter brand and two
years later, spending more money
on Facebook and Instagram than does.
- Mhm
- Like if you go talk to
Facebook executives that
run their business, they're
getting way bigger budgets
from companies you've never heard of
and that is probably my favorite thing
that's kind of going on.
Literally, literally, when
you look at the top spenders
on these platforms, it
will blow your mind.
Literally a brand you've never heard of
and that's because one
trades on sales data
and another one trades on
internal MMMs or reporting.
- Coming back to your earlier
point, is there danger
in building your whole
brand on one platform?
- Yes.
- What's the danger of that?
- You become one dimensional
and a one dimensional
fighter is vulnerable.
(chuckling)
- Well what I resear--
- And again, instead of
just making a fun statement,
let me add a little bit to that.
Look, every time you're
looking for growth, you know,
this is actually a fun
way to create some clarity
about how I think about the world.
I don't hate traditional media.
I think over a long period of
time, it became overpriced.
I actually love outdoor, for example.
Outdoor gets seen, you know?
Not everybody's looking at their
phone every second and if you really like,
I love UIing apps in real life
so I like outdoor quite a bit.
I just like to buy it when it's remnant
and I can buy it for one
month for 2000 bucks instead
of the 24 thousand they want when
you buy it for six month contract.
So to me, the danger of
being one dimensional is,
why would you wanna be
one dimensional, right?
You're gonna squeeze the
crap out of one fruit
and you've squeezed all
the orange juice out
of the orange but there's
a grapefruit right here
and you should start, and even
if the grapefruit's small,
there's still juice in there and so to me,
I think about overpriced
and underpriced attention
and as real estate prices
come down in a soft economy
and more internet business,
inevitably its gonna turn
and storefronts are gonna be a good buy.
So, there's a bunch of companies
that are about to go out
of business because they signed
big leases seven years ago,
didn't factor in e-com,
and they're underwater,
they'll go, demand for retail,
everyone's a headline reader like
don't buy retail, it's the internet.
So, what will happen is
demand will go down so
retail, in two to three
years, especially if
the economy gets soft, is gonna be
a fucking deal for these brands that
get walk in traffic.
Still, I mean everybody
here bought something
in the store recently, so
yeah, there's just no reason
to be one dimensional.
- Mhm, What do you think
about these brands moving
into physical retail spaces?
Hardee's in the U.K.
has just done a big deal
with Boots pharmacy.
- I saw.
I'm into it.
I think you expand your business,
you've got the leverage as a DTC brand.
You know, the old world
was, you started a brand
and you fucking paid to get
even a prayer of getting in.
Now, you build a $100 million
business direct to consumer
and you're going in with leverage.
This is one big game of leverage.
- Well, I want to take some
questions from our audience
if there are any, before
Gary has to catch his flight
We'll just do it now.
- [Man] I'll ask a question.
Your recent campaign with K
Swiss, you were out, I saw them.
- Thank you.
- [Man] it's incredible by the way.
- [Man] That's very much a branded piece
by yourself I imagine.
Where do you see that going, you know,
and where does this kind of fit into
your vision of doing brands?
- So, just to catch up everybody,
this week we launched the fourth
collaboration with K Swiss
and what we decided to do
this time was do an above,
you know I love eating my own dog food,
so I'm yelling at everybody
for not doing longer form
brand videos to drive their business,
and so I said then I'll do it for this.
And then I said what's
underpriced attention?
Influencers are underpriced
so I reach out to a huge slew
of influencers who follow
me and offered to pay them
and we made a very long form
video at Vayner productions.
I was very uninvolved obviously,
besides sitting and answering questions,
which they used some of it in the video,
but very little me in
comparison to everything else.
We made a long form video that
a bunch of influencers posted
for awareness and it
was just a brand piece.
It was just kind of more
similar to the stuff
I normally put out but
more production value.
No different than the Dwyane
Wade Budweiser piece we did
or the Maxwell piece we did and the impact
on sales was extraordinary.
It drastically outperformed
clouds and dirt,
which was more sales,
more of that approach
and so you can imagine,
and here's the best part,
back to not caring about about outdoor
or radio or television.
I didn't care if it was gonna
fail because I know creative
is the variable of success,
but it worked extremely well.
- [Man] There's a lot of emotion as well
that you put into it. That was--
- Yeah I mean look--
I apologize for cutting you off,
if you're gonna make content,
you need people to feel
something when it's done.
Whether they laugh, they cry, they think,
like, yo I mean that was,
that was the most important.
If the video sucked shit, we wouldn't have
sold sneakers, you know?
And so, we went with the
brand approach on digital
because, like I said
in some meetings today
with some of the leaders,
I believe that digital,
Facebook, Instagram, YouTube LinkedIn,
is the place to build brand,
not do lower funnel sales.
I think that's the place
to do two, three, four,
five, six minute videos
'cause I think that's
the place where people
are consuming information.
It's not super complicated.
And once everybody wraps
their head around it,
it's so funny to see the
creative landscape push
against this 'cause they put the emotion
and the ideology of TVC
on a pedestal, meanwhile,
every creative on Earth
would much rather have
two minutes and 13 seconds
to tell a story than 30
or at least the appropriate amount of time
to tell the story versus being confined
to a 30, a 15, or a six.
- You mentioned influencers there,
what influence do they
have in this DTC world?
- A huge role.
Influencers by nature are a creative
and distribution media
all in the price of one
with the word of mouth
affirmation and cosigning.
They're the great deal of our
industry, yet there's enormous
scrutiny around it because people like
headline reading instead
of being practitioners.
- Does anyone have any more
questions that they want to ask?
- [Sam] What's the best--
- What's your name?
.[Sam] I'm Sam.
- Sam.
- [Sam] And that's some
smart work you guys.
- Thank you.
- [Sam] How do we keep
track of which channels
are undervalued?
Say at the moment Apple
might not be valued--
- It's a great question, we
were just having this debate
upstairs like look,
what you measure against
is so imperative, right?
You know, to me, if I'm a business,
I'm trying to suffocate the
shit out of everything I do
to prove to me that it's driving.
So for example, if I'm a retailer,
which I grew up one so this
one comes natural to me,
I wanna do branded outdoor
with actually a product
in offering and not offer that product
in offering anywhere else in the world so
that I've suffocated the
variables to understand
that that was the channel
that drove the behavior
in my 713 stores against
a $49,000 production cost
and a $637,000 outdoor media spend.
And the fact that we don't do that,
over time made me realize how much
the industry doesn't want to figure out
the actual answers, you know?
Suffocating, having the actual intent.
We do a lot of digital buying
where we're doing one mile,
two mile radius media spend
against specific offer
and we can show that, you know,
there's a uptake in foot
traffic versus your baseline
and your average sale is higher than
it was before because we
clustered out other stores
where they didn't do that.
I mean, if you have true
intent to prove the ROI
and you're lucky enough to
have some sort of transaction
of some sorts, or something
to anchor to, even
if it's a Nielsen rating on
TV, which is their currency,
or votes or whatever it may
be, you will get the answer.
If it's simply brand health,
then somebody's making
a subjective call, no matter
what report they use as gospel.
- Any other questions, anyone else?
- [Audience Member] Empathy
Wine, is it coming to the UK?
- Yes
- When?
- We just had this discussion with them,
we're working on it.
We, one thing that was
very important to me is
if this wine went into new markets,
that that market didn't pay a extra vig,
where it was just paying more
than the American consumer
or to the best of my ability
'cause sometimes you g--
Like we're going to
Canada, Canada is a Mafia.
The whole country owns
the whole ecosystem,
you can only do so much, so we're looking
at several options.
I think I'd be surprised
if we weren't here
within the next six months.
Yeah, I'm really excited about it.
- [Sam] It's Sam.
- Sam.
- [Sam] I have another question.
- By the way, did you guys
see Gary will be extinct
in the U.K. by 2050, you see that article?
(laughing)
- [Audience Member] Not since 1992.
- There's not been a single kid named Gary
in the U.K. since 1992.
(laughing)
- I'm gonna super focus
on my brand in this region
to inspire at least one transaction.
Exactly.
Real quick, and I apologize
because this is gonna be
of value, I failed almost every
class I took except history
and I never ever, and I mean
this, knew why until recently.
Basically, the reason I
end up being right about
a lot of things is the conversation you
and I just had, everything repeats itself.
It's pattern recognition, that's right.
That's why these brands
are in deep fucking shit
if they don't start building a real brand.
What they're doing that
scare the fuck out of me,
is I think they're wasting 85 to 90 cents
on every dollar they spend
on marketing doing old things
with old reports, which is
the only thing they can do,
which is contemporary branding
to build relevance to offset the
deep technology disadvantages
they're sitting with.
- [Audience Member] So
what would you do if
you were the retailers?
- Build a brand, because
when this goes to voice,
and I say, Alexa, book me a hotel,
I'd better say Alexa, book me a Marriott
or Marriott's gonna be upset.
Alexa, book me a Four Seasons
or they're gonna be upset,
because when voice becomes the toll booth,
not search, everyone's in
deep shit because with search,
at least you have a prayer
of seeing another result.
With voice, Amazon and
Google pick and then
when Amazon and Google
actually buy Starwood,
people are very confused what's about
to happen in the world.
I think I'm less confused.
(laughing)
- And that's what, I do
things that people make fun of
and later revere.
So, I highly recommend if
you're capable of dealing
with judgment and you
have conviction, to do it.
It always works out in the end.
- Nice, okay I think that's
a real nice place to end on.
Please stay in touch with us.
- I agree, see ya!
Have fun, I gotta run.
I'm sure some people wanna talk,
but I'm legitimately gonna
miss this so have fun,
thank you so much. Thanks for coming.
(applauding)